I really need to say a major and huge
thank you to our YouTube subscribers who
now number more than 750,000 this
happened yesterday so we're just past
that number 750,000 now I'm just
flattered and so inspired when we first
started this channel I think in the
first month we had four subscribers
maybe it was ten I struggle to remember
we now are gaining several hundred
subscribers every single day and it's
extremely exciting as we now get into an
election year which is often when growth
accelerates and we are really positioned
to get to the next level I mean in the
youtubes left thanks to your support and
I'm talking about the trolls as well I'm
thanking the trolls as well and I'll
detail that in a second you've got the
Young Turks with four and a half million
subscribers and then you have the David
Pakman show Kyle kolinsky and Sam cedar
all in the 700 to 800 thousand
subscriber range so this is a great
place to be it's great company to share
and now let me get to the trolls and the
haters I have to thank them as well the
trolls and the haters who make it a
point to dislike my videos and leave a
whole bunch of hate comments on them you
were actually a huge part of the success
as well individually the trolls are
really annoying
in total the trolls represent a portion
of the engagement on the channel that
has helped us grow dislikes count as
engagement you see a video and you were
motivated to dislike it that means
you're engaging with the content
negative angry comments while many of
the comments are vile in their content
they are engagement and they say to the
YouTube algorithm Wow the content here
is getting people to take action the
frequency with which someone is liking
or disliking or leaving a comment that
is a huge piece of the YouTube algorithm
learning whose videos are likely to
generate a reaction and discussion and
keep people watching so genuinely thank
you not only to the supporters but to
the trolls as well all those comments
saying David your show your show and
your channel are
your show is circling the drain by
leaving me those comments and by
disliking my videos you're helping to
ensure that it's not the case and that
the show keeps growing so
extraordinarily exciting year coming up
is my prediction as of right now we are
sort of projected based on current
subscriber growth rates to be close to a
million subscribers around election 2020
now my hope is that as we really get
into the 2020 election primaries Trump
unhinged all of that stuff I hope that
our growth rate will accelerate slightly
and push the 1 million subscriber
milestone 2 before the 2020 election it
would be amazing it is a stretch goal
but it would be amazing for us to be a 1
million plus subscriber YouTube channel
by the time that we get to the 2020
election and you know in the end the
truth is really what matters is views
because you don't have to be subscribed
to view the content some people often
tell me you know David Dave Reubens
YouTube channel is so much more
successful than yours he's got a million
subscribers we have roughly double the
views of Dave Reubens channel and that
is really the most important thing but
there's no question that subscribers are
sort of a very front and center
barometer for how a channel is doing so
we're gonna continue doing our thing 750
feels like a great number to be at this
point in time I look forward to
continuing on in 2020 with more content
more long-form pieces more daily
political news interviews and everything
else that's been working for us so far
opportunities for you to help do you
want to be a moderator of our YouTube
live streams we do need help with that
because they are getting so big and out
of control that our current moderators
are overwhelmed get in touch via email
through the contact form on my website
if you want to be a YouTube moderator
send a link to your youtube profile do
you want to be a moderator on our
subreddit the subreddit is now one of
the largest subreddits based around a
single show on the progressive left
we need more moderators we only have I
think four and we have nearly 16,000
subscribers on the subreddit that is a
volunteer opportunity
as always if you want to contribute
graphics memes funny things we can use
on social media or whatever the case may
be it is an open door and so much great
stuff has come from the audience so all
meant many many opportunities and if
nothing else click the subscribe button
right now if you're watching this and
you are not one of our 750,000
subscribers add your name to the list
click that subscribe button